welcome to this video coverage for the
final round of the Norway chess
tournament 2014 yeah this ninth round is
still full of suspense as it is not
decided yet before the round we have fun
kayaking surprisingly leading the field
after two wins um yeah but I one bit on
the lucky side I guess one of those wins
against Giri but he's in the lead and
today play some black against koala now
also with a win could get into the the
positive region of the table and
theoretically speaking could still share
first also we have the world champion
magnus cars with the plus one squared go
two plus two and catch kiya can i it's a
matter of the result of those two games
okay what I'm going to do is this time
I'm going to look at all the games um
and I don't do a yeah particularly game
of the day which is a lot longer or more
detailed than the others I'm simply
going on to solve the games in order of
importance so the two decisive games for
the tournament will come last so that
there are some suspense in this video in
case you don't know the result um ok
let's start and this will be a very
quick coverage Giri playing swidler both
are mistaken on minus one very unexcited
tournament Giri had very good chances to
to make it a good tournament but he lost
this epic 131 in both game against
kayaking from a winning position and
instead of him having a chance to catch
her to get to catch up or get in the
lead it was kayaking who did this so on
the tournament decided was decided for
giving a couple of days ago or two I
think through days ago ok let's see what
happened we have a symmetrical English
again which is the opening
the tournament playing all the time they
play that okay this line here with a 3
this is a common line they are black
very often sets up ahead chakra
formation and after a couple of moves
this in fact happens one drawback for
black is that the night is on c6 which
is not ideal you normally want your
night to be on d7 one reason why this is
important is that this shot is quite
often a problem in fact here Giri could
have played that I mean this is the idea
leading to an awkward pin here on the
night but this is not that dramatic
black can retreat it looks a bit a bit
weird but it's not leading to to all
that much um yeah okay please Bishop e3
could be a tall this is fairly standard
stuff nothing much happening and here in
this position after Bishop h4 Bishop e7
Bishop f2 you get the sneaky suspicion
right they drew the game here with the
perpetual and over the perpetual with
the repetition of moves which was
certainly not forced but well I
understand the players I mean they
couldn't really do much in the terms of
final standings and especially give you
was certainly very disappointed after
this 130 move loss Sevilla had a very
bad game yesterday against Carlton Bay
was totally lost and somehow
miraculously was gifted draw in a way
and so I understand the players it's not
great to watch but yeah last last round
so I think this is sometimes just
understandable okay next game is too pal
of aronia here i mostly want to look at
one or two spots for the file
outstanding this game also has no
relevance whatsoever they both armed
cannot get
to the lead anymore yeah we have a
Berlin Berlin defense with d3 and very
um yeah slow build-up from white with d
3333 c3 and aronian sets up a very solid
defensive position with bishop to g7
fianchetto would ya after some journey
but it's very typical of the royal pest
and in fact there isn't that much
happening it's a fairly quiet game well
white maintain some slide slide pool
very slight however we get to a critical
position rather quickly just a couple of
moves later why test now initiated this
play in the center with d4 yeah auntie
em and the next couple of moose aquaria
are very interesting queen bee files
plate which is maybe not ideal after
that it seems to be difficult to black
to to keep a quality um after Luke see
one white has a very substantial threat
and the absolutely weird thing here is
that I mean the threat is all I'm saying
obviously but I really think obviously
obviously d5 and yeah I'm attacking the
knight and if it moves away c7 is gone
it's not exactly def difficult but our
own young played Bishop g7 strangely
enough it wasn't necessary to do that I
mean you could play it c5 which is not a
happy mood white is better but there's
probably nothing nothing better
available no but with the totally
amazing thing is ok he played Bishop g7
yeah and now after some thought almost
10 minutes topalov played age four and
it's really a mystery to me why he
didn't take on beehive I mean I didn't
see the press conference but it would be
interesting to know because
I mean after d5 right it's just winning
c7 and the lines connected with this are
really really easy to calculate I mean I
would be interesting to know and what
what she was afraid of for example if we
look at this white is just breaking
through their only thing that black can
do is get one poem back but then night
c2 maybe he had underestimated this move
I'm not sure I mean but look at this
here black is really close to
resignation b7 is falling or you must
play a super passive move like rugby aid
and this is just a technical window
almost fine yeah b5 is also very very
weak pawned it can sometimes just picked
up like like this for example yeah it's
mysterious um yeah Knight g4 is also
possible but this is pretty much the
same also an excellent position for
white very close to a win and yeah on
top of all of that if you don't take
there's also d5 and this is a after
Queen takes rook takes its this is also
very very convincing for wide huge you
judge yeah I have no idea what t'appelle
offer was doing here I played age four
and after c5 from there there is nothing
for what absolutely nothing you have
this these traits and Luke c8 and now
those two pawns are simply too weak yeah
don't have made some very mysterious
decisions in the tournament I mean King
age eight against Geary where instead of
having a cleared she just blundered it
away and this is some quite comparable I
mean d5 is a very easy move then it's
not like you didn't see it of course he
saw it and he calculated Lions but
somehow in the
in those calculations there must have
been a point where he he missed
something yeah auntie em I don't want to
get to this too too deeply um like I'm
always getting out of material back the
only slightly remarkable thing was the
final position which was totally
symmetrical okay don't have that too
often after 41 moves yeah a game where
two part of relatively easily could have
could have won yeah Aronian also had a
very young mediocre tournament for his
standards a bad one but it seems that I
only read that and somewhere that in the
final round press conference he stated
that he um wasn't 100% the health he
hadn't minor yeah I don't know is it
English the same thing operation yeah he
in here to go to a hospital and have
something fixed and it seems to be all
right now but there was some yeah he
wasn't 100% fit already after this okay
but it seems that for the for the
olympiad in the beginning of August he
expects to be on one hundred percent
again okay so next game crown degree
shock yeah and now let's don't and let's
not screw this up from nick is on is he
on fifty percent is on fifty percent and
we shook i think as well yeah so they
both cannot win the tournament anymore
and chroma key especially certainly
disappointed after he lost the round
before that 2k aachen but it's got the
white pieces against michigan certainly
a fight is in order so we have a green
felt and chrome nick is playing the
Bishop e3 line one of the lines that he
has played regularly over the years some
I'm not an expert here I was surprised
though that this is highly uncommon the
slide it looks very very normal for the
gruene thought at least what what I'm
thinking is normal but it seems to be a
relatively new bishop f3 seems to be a
new move and okay maybe I'm not having
all the games relevant here but it seems
that this is a sideline and it has a
very concrete IDM google puts the bishop
on d4 quite interesting um yeah what is
basically forced to take it otherwise
black will take and get a fantastic
night only five so the capture is pretty
much forced see takes deep castles very
logical and now 95 yeah very interesting
and enforcing a way to play if wide now
retreat the bishop like that there's the
three and this is a are not ideal here
see for as a weakness and this close to
falling actually yeah it's probably best
to take on d4 cromley did they both
plate rather quickly so it may be
awesome not unknown to them yeah an i
decree plate note that the move Queen
takes f 3 which looks attractive it
first assesses winning a pisser can be
easily refuted by Queen takes d5 check a
queen a three and black gets this pawn
here yeah so let's take stock it's equal
material the White King looks a bit
exposed and like is threatening a
perpetual check at the moment now on the
other hand white has an excellent Center
and with Roxy three the perpetual of
course is some prevent
yeah it's very tough to play this
position black structure is very compact
only issue is of course the mission the
mission the missing goon felt Bishop on
g7 so blacks King site is slightly
weakened his King position is slightly
weakened and yeah white enjoys this very
young yeah very big center it is however
very double-edged as yeah White's king
is also exposed and those pawns about
being aggressively posted in advance can
also be weak it seems that the coming
was Grisha took this pawn yeah this is a
one sacrifice by what that the upcoming
move so seem to be a very good play at
least the engine or engines and do not
have any any objection about the moves
white seems to have a sufficient
compensation for the material and this
is quite quite clears for the human eye
that this a big advance center must
provide something it's not just white
being a porn down however it is very
difficult to play Queen B 2 is setting
up a pin and Jack we are here Jack now
here Kramnik all he already could have
drawn with Luke f1 black has no way to
escape that it's a perpetual attack on
the Queen but chronic wanted to win the
game and he also has some more time on
the clock and he pushed with luke g3 and
allowed the black Queen to go back this
isn't a mistake it's just taking a risk
he could have drawn already this is now
in the game against kayaking that he
lost he also had a draw on the board and
didn't didn't do it okay he fights on d6
using the the past pawn and giving up
yet another pawn once
for ya it was taken by grey chakra
already was in severe time travel as we
can expect queen bee three yeah and here
we get to him to a critical position of
the game it seems that here of course is
a an amazingly complicated position with
those advanced pawns and the white not
this the white active rooks em um yeah
he agree shocked um makes a mistake
which is quickly pointed out by by a
computer but for a human player this is
hell the others position he played look
to g4 it seems that rube deform first is
better which attacks the Queen and only
after the Queen retreats rook g-form it
seems to be better one reason is that
the Queen now is not supporting the deep
on here after d5 it seems that um the
position should end in a draw the game
should end in a draw White has yeah
White has a big attack simply for
example like this I mean a big attack to
learn to steer the game towards the
perpetual something like this is aligned
that the computer gifts and here white
can draw 96 there are obviously many
many possibilities here it is a
super-sharp position but Gavin the
computer gives it a sequel so this was
the right way to play but very very
difficult for human to to do he played
Luke g4 immediately and this in fact
gives chronic a chance which he does not
take on chronic played d7 in this
position which is yeah not not
illogically are pushing the porn but it
seems that the capture on g6 was a very
close to a wide win
if we look at this a bit if black takes
this seems to be the winning really the
poem threatens with promotion in the eye
to look 28 there is a six and now black
falls apart yeah this is this is too
much now the f porn must move and here
that's also Luke CA this is this is
deadly absolutely so after the capture
probably black must recapture with the
age porn and now d 7 yeah we already
seen the idea if black now plays through
28 there is a six and black is not going
to survive that yeah just the possible
line if he takes this Queen f3 okay
Black has no check and Queen f7 is a is
a very very strong thread or if black
takes check this check mate this made it
to move yeah and this is a very very
strong attack it seems that after the
seven black actually must allow the
promotion with the mouflon King g7 this
is however not one hundred percent clear
um I guess white white should win but
I'm a bit reluctant to call it
completely winning it is sister very
tricky I'm sorry like takes white shakes
and to now check with this sequence
black as black as a ton of checks yeah
and will not probably I'm just putting a
sample line on here he will get for
instance here we'll get the platform and
black has four pawns for a look this
shouldn't be enough as why it is not so
badly coordinated let's say after this
maybe white can really continue the
attack on the black king but this is not
totally clear to me I mean it should win
for white but it's not
not totally easy F takes a g6 was very
very strong and probably winning for
what but chronic played d7 and now goo
shock could go back with rook t4 and he
needed to do that this was forced yeah
and he Parmalee had 16 minutes on the
clock he had some time to to calculate
and it seems that here there is only one
playable with only one and the computer
is now telling me there are two moose
yeah well um interesting in my analysis
I had quinsy to as as being a move that
black and a white can play still keeping
this threat alive and yeah something
like let's say queen b 5f takes g6
Quincy five I'm stuff done something
wrong here this is this is really weird
look D for Quincy to this is what you
played young Queen c2 I wonder ever have
some mistake in my file FG six the Queen
D 7 alla I'm ok I'm ok quindi seven she
takes King age aid and this counter
flavor white should probably enough to
to draw the game um I was quite
surprised that this also seems to be
moved Chang hmm interesting Queenie for
Jack funny yeah and now the promotion is
threatened of course if like place this
there's this cool move very nice yeah so
white forces promotion you can finally
give some some checks here but now it's
it's gone the DLF porn
strong it's funny so FK x 26 was also
possible not with a win because black
ken can do this him Jack Jack King g7 is
still okay yeah so White had had ways to
continue he end at least for a draw but
from Nick played Queen f3 after how much
time did you invest almost nothing
amazing yeah that's really amazing yeah
okay Bri shock only has one minute
something on his clock but he still
found the right movie 6 now and after
e-cigs blackest flat-out winning there
is absolutely nothing that white can do
here you are simply with e6 prevent any
e6 s from white and the d7 point is
falling yeah here there is not much to
find commonly played f6 hoping for this
this made on g7 but it's not not easy to
do took him and with route 28 black was
ready to cover g7 soak Romney casa had
terribly bungled up with this I mean he
had enough initiative and attack for the
material to at least secure draw at one
point probably get an edge even but the
way it was played Grisha glossen was
just winning and right after new 40 here
prom Nick resigned the game so I'm an
absolutely disappointing end of this
tournament for the former world champion
he has he had started with the plus to
score he was leading the tournament and
then out of the last four games he just
got one half point losing three games
and at the end being on minus one and
yeah this was very disappointing of
course lots of the losses were really a
bit self-inflicted here he could have
repeated moves yesterday against
kayaking but tried and lost and today he
had chances and at least of course for a
draw but also for doing more but it
didn't work out ordered the ante he even
lost the game so very disappointing
finish form for kramnik yeah good shock
at the enter is finishing on a plus one
score which is yeah not terrible but he
certainly had hoped for more as yet
expect is expressed already in the press
conference I think after round seven
around eight so okay so let's now look
at carleton octa Stein so Carson
absolutely must win the game everything
else is it's not acceptable in a way
yeah in falmouth certainly he would have
thought so before the tournament that
you should win this but in the current
standings with kayaking leading Garza
needs to win to at least have chances
for four playoff they have a rapid
playoff in case of a time okay we have D
for I'd we get a Queen's Indian and a
pretty solid way to play d 5 is somewhat
sharper continuation on the black side
directly trying to attack white center
but white can for the moment ignore that
if black takes here there is always a 95
getting to an interesting position
playable for black though it's not not
terrible alright but he played this
check and went back yeah after Knight c3
castles castles and D takes e4 wide went
95 and I'm not an expert on this opening
a door and I didn't really look this up
if this is a known position but if you
ask me hmm
white seems to be in quite good shape
here he's got a good central control is
better developed and after c6 b.tech see
Quincy seven white already had a very
pleasant choice how to continue I would
have been very tempted to play a for I
must admit setting up this broad center
and maybe if Black permits even push
efore and sort of play four pawns attack
against the Queen's Indian this really
would be quite nice to get so f4 was
certainly not bad calculate Bishop f4
though also keeping keeping an advantage
at least why this more comfortable
Bishop e7 group c 1 yeah sort of a
general or general grounds good move 9h
5 and drought here it is not clear what
is the best continuation he went knight
to e form the computer likes be should
be three and what I like G is III yeah
this is the move I was thinking of and
then I was glad that Nigel short we was
doing commentary on this also suggested
the move I always liked this idea to
answer night h5 with this in this type
of structure not in this Pacific
position it leads to information like
that were white with those two points
has a very very serious grip on e5 and
he has a very nice support for the night
only five I would have liked this very
much disposition but ok carlinne move is
not bad of course 94 this leads to a
similar information with this pawns on
d4 and F for quite some funny
intermediate moves always this mate on a
mates on 87 yeah and we got to this
position and this is quite an
interesting structure White has two
double points this
this year but of course this is no
weakness why this especially with the
corns i-95 and a4a gaining space and
also has the idea to put a knight on f6
they have six flags really weak as as
the matter of fact the whole king
position of black looks a bit weak on
the other hand we already have some some
pieces traded and black is defined
defending really really nicely putting
the Night Elves on g4 first yeah and now
putting it on f5 and this is a good
position for the night it is securely
placed and white really does not want to
play you form em yeah in fact this was
an interesting move it looks at first
completely anti positional yeah as a
black hops in on d4 on the other hand
white has some taking chances so he can
try to to bring the rook up on look III
g3 and he has got quite some space
available it would have been interesting
to play that but causes stylists to play
a bit more conservatively out same and
he went for this doubling on the D farm
this however does not give any advantage
absolutely absolutely not um yeah here
black plate rook t4 is probably not the
most precise move because after e3 you
take any way but it wasn't really a
measuring much black traded down and
when droop the ATM the reduction of
material is certainly helpful for for
black yakking f1 ya a little trick black
cannot take the route guess yeah 98 is a
big Fork king fa I know we have those
traits yeah how to assess this position
it is probably
would best play equal black does not
really need to fear this night that much
but in a practical game it is terribly
annoying to always face the prospect to
get some some czechia on the aid or
whatever and then queen and night is I
checking and yeah meeting the black king
on the other hand the Black Knight yeah
on f5 as mentioned it was a good in the
middle game it was a good defensive post
right here the night is not doing
anything basically default ected d6 is
protected you can go back at some moment
but other than that the night is doing
nothing so I think this is very much
easier to play for white despite the
fact that it might be a might be equal
with the absolute best play against the
computer for example you probably won't
win this but why this white is easier to
play Magnus is playing those lulu
strengthening moves and activates the
screen nidus tree rooted yeah to attack
f7 this was probably a good idea and now
artists artists going for b5 this this I
found surprising because I wasn't really
sure how white would make any progress
if black is just just staying basically
if you sit and wait but b5 is probably
probably not really bad between d3
basics if you went to be 6 yeah Black
has a three against two majority here so
on paper theoretically speaking yeah
he's someone with with the possibility
to get a passed pawn but all this is not
as relevant as the snide always
attacking f7 so the black Queen has been
basically tied to the pawn and this
really means that this majority yeah
it's nice to have but probably it's not
something that you can use to play for
windows play
yeah in fact we have a couple of more
moves which don't really change the
assessment that much now we get to this
to this situation here Knight to c3 yeah
and here I'm octa Stein is T Clancy form
and it seems that this is the only real
mistake that he commits in the whole
game but it proves very costly um it
seems that Queen a5 was a good way to to
play this he's protecting b5 with the
Queen and if white Jack tries to invade
him Black has said this check here after
which um yeah this is this for example
is leading to an immediate wrong Weidman
must probably give the perpetual and if
white retreats black can take it has got
this counter play this is a perpetual
check but it's very difficult to
calculate all this as you always see
those girls the other night giving
checks and whatnot yeah he M decided to
take here and after Queen takes now it
gets very very problematic the problem
is Queen 84 and the invasion or queen a4
and the invasion and it's really a
dramatic yeah what what the engine shows
yet so it's far more than than a pawn
for white and it gets increasingly
difficult to offend Jack yeah around yet
so it's it's probably gone why does
attacking and compared to the line we
had seen before they're simply a pawn on
c4 missing which is the important
counterplay device yeah here we played
c4 but if black takes there is nice
check also quite nice can easily be
missed sometimes and in this little time
on the clock yes he for was tried
and now Queen f8 the item f7 is falling
there is simply nothing that I can do
the night is also joining the tech check
check check check ya series of checks
Jack and he rocked assign resigned the
game the easiest continuation is king c5
jack so just this way to play Jay and
tier black only has Queen B 5 which can
happily be taken by the octopus an ID on
T 6 yeah wind for cards and at the end
so he has done his job that he needs to
do in the final round getting two plus
two this is all in all not a very
satisfactory result for him especially
considering that he had this totally
winning position against villa in round
8 with the win in this round eight game
and yeah same he would have won this as
well in the same situation he would have
gotten two plus rescore and would have
had at least the shared tournament
victory in the back which certainly
would have been okay with him but this
way I mean no matter what if he reaches
the tribe breaks or not we will learn
that in the next game you certainly
wouldn't be very satisfied with this
result i only won two games here and in
one of the games against uronian he was
worse very much worse okay so the game
kawana kayaking is the decisive one
let's see what they played yeah
amazingly another symmetrical English
this is really becoming very popular
here and German kiwanis playing with the
very quick a three this is an
interesting way to play we had seen this
before I just wanted to point out one
little detail it's an easy one but still
it happens time and time again if black
plays in five
yeah this is a mistake because of night
xe5 yeah little tactical motif worth
remembering you know this is a pawn at
the end one Knight c3 there is this type
of desperado yeah here black and can
theoretically speaking take further I
like like here but it's it's a total of
the total desperado yeah white cane sir
the in the night and has an extra point
night XD five is a neat little trick
this is also the reason why black
retreats to c7 he wants to get in e5 now
a 3 plate yeah and this in a way
discourages you 5s then why it has this
before idea they are probably after
castles and right here it's also
playable the general idea being this and
why does and very good shape though a 3
it's interesting it in a way provokes
like to play with g6 they're bad news
for widest this is also very valid setup
and it's not clear that in this g six
lines you really want a three being
played yeah to be honest them I think
that this is a big nothing for white if
we look at this black has got the
Knights on c6 andy sixx this is very a
similar to the giri kayaking game maybe
it's just the same position i could have
looked that up really it's very very
very similar yeah again koala is doing
something ambitious now he wants to
fight maybe win the game and still get a
shot a shared first place but if we look
at the position here yeah after all
these trades blacks got the bishop am
and this fairly solid so this cannot be
a too great for what it's certainly ok
but it shouldn't be anything anything
great yeah let's see what happens he
plays with this b5 move fixing those
pawns and long-term trying to attack and
take them
also see six now is a spot where white
piece might be used effectively castles
d for Brooks e7 yeah and to hear white
made a very remarkable move which I
would have been very reluctant to play
but he was obviously deeply irritated by
black threatening to play in 75 in the
long run or maybe in the short run he
played the move f4 you know this is a
move that is some you are not very
desirable when positionally as two weeks
III g3 you don't have don't have a dark
square Bishop anymore but it makes sure
that if I is not being played so maybe
it was some yeah born out of necessity
in a way the whole arm situation is
probably about about balanced yup like
is centralizing and now trying to
activate his bishop now a five very
interesting moment here and he karana
plays a very ambitious Lee probably ok
but ambitiously he could have taken on
on a six of courses at home passel which
after this is I guess quite equal he
wanted more and probably it this was an
ok decision white now get some his fair
share and better share of the C file and
even manages to were to enter here on c6
this is always interesting those kind of
advanced squares and we're we see one
important point of it you sometimes can
sacrifice an exchange to establish a
very strong pawn this in fact it didn't
happen in the game would have led to a
fantastic position for white the IDS
night b5 and c7 and you cannot go here
because of Queen III which is very
strong
attacking here attacking here and this
is very good for white black black
cannot really take the exchange and this
is annoying you always have to do lift
with this rook for a moment yeah e6 was
played and this controls d5 so maybe the
capture is a bit more likely now that
maybe 95 is also not possible yeah
kawana retreated because he has spotted
this idiom getting the bishops traded
here and getting the rook to c6 after
that now queen d6 was played yeah and by
now it is quite quite serious white now
has the chance to really get something
in this game and this is with the move
Knight to e4 this seems to lead to a
quite substantial advantage for white
let's say Queenie 7 there's not much
else no this position seems to be very
good for white b6 is weak and yeah the
only counterplay of course is connected
with the a porn but this is not so quick
this might be a line to be considered
you see that night c4 is also the
possibility very strong square for the
night attacking b6 and helping to stop
the a pawn in this situation it is
really critical for black I don't know
not sure if he would have had a chance
to to save the game and in this in this
line maybe instead of look b7 there's a
form trying to play a more actively we
can we can try to check that
oops Group B seven and again in this 96
yeah 94 was very strong for white but it
wasn't played back Ilana he has not so
much time on the clock he played night
to a for directly attacking the pawn
which is also a very tempting move it's
not like it doesn't make any sense like
took on c6 understandable and rook takes
and queen before and this is what he
probably had missed or missing misjudged
in a way the night is hanging and okay
it must move or must be protected if we
look at Knight b6 there is queen bee
hive and this is really not what wide
wanted giving up the b5 poor now means
that this is not a good outpost anymore
and yeah don't forget White has moved
all his pawns and has a very weak King
there are moves like this threat and so
now with the queenside yang
deteriorating it gets more and more
problematic that white is weakened so
much and the apron is in existence very
tricky now to play he played after Queen
before maybe Queen D 1 was the toughest
he played 93 yeah and now I'm passed
pawns must be pushed there's a for their
very very difficult to play now look b6
yeah this move coming is absolutely not
good it's very comparable to the game
the game you played this move and after
a three took root CA droop c6 and Quincy
form the very logical continuation but
also a very lost continuation this is a
super dangerous pawn there's Bishop
before as the direct threat and white
really does not have any decimals plate
c7 is the only one that it's not
directly losing
Queen takes Queen B 3 and now queen f5
again going from this route with an
activation of the Queen and care what
why this without any defense he played
this Queen B to us again threatened yeah
this is covered but I mentioned yeah all
this has been weakened by a fourth f4
it's always a double-edged move it is
good and serves its purpose in the
middle game but later when the position
opens up that can very often backfire on
you the compact black position here with
the King being totally safe is here
simply more yeah more beneficial 95 and
this is falling yeah it wasn't really
possible anymore to cover anything here
if we let's say here to cover it jack
black is already breaking through yeah
this is just picking up Jack pieces
exactly some chicks check yeah this pin
this is decisive here kawana resigned
the night is hanging and this means that
basically there is one of the trade and
now the a pond is just doing the home
run so kayaking won this game with black
in the final round against kawana which
means he has won this thing he has won
the tournament and I think this is a
pretty much sensation after yeah if you
would would start video at the point of
move 120 in the game against Gary you
would have seen kayaking is on fifty
percent in this tournament and he's dead
lost in this game and then Geary
blunders it away giving kayaking this
point on on a silver plate he is on +1
aha
anyplace Kramnik was not willing to take
a draw somehow despite the position
being equal he then yeah he continues to
play and the kayaking does a good job he
wraps this up uses all chrome legs
inaccurate moves yeah and then here in
this game it was it was a tough fight at
one point white had an advantage but it
wasn't it wasn't like a direct winner
but white could have done something but
he fought this way to yet another
victory so he won this tournament at the
end with a score of plus three and just
just a moment write her back now and
have managed to somehow wriggles this
window in the video yeah just to have a
quick overview of the final standings
kayaking with six points this plus three
score we see that he had a loss early
this minus sign sig symbolizing the loss
he lost against aronia and after that he
won four games yeah he won against them
karana around four and then had those
three consecutive wins at the end
Carlton the only player without a loss
he won against Aronian this this this
tough game yeah where he was very much
worse at some point and the final round
against ACTA Stein so not a catastrophe
not a catastrophe and this is also very
much a secret not a secret but a
trademark of Carlton see I think he now
as for more than three years never
played a tournament below 2800
performance rating which is remarkable
really um yeah but ok he certainly
expected more and the game against with
Louis really something else yet we
should had an up-and-down tournament he
lost 12 lost again yeah through 40 sides
of gamesome then a couple of fighting
draws with chances he could have beaten
Geary probably yeah very good position
there and he won last round against
chronic 4+1 score even gaining a couple
of you know points corona certainly a.m.
yeah disappointed he started with two
wins and then got only two losses at the
end here with a couple of drawers fifty
percent is probably not living up to to
its own standards yet to pull off with
fifty percent he played a roller coaster
tournament as so often lost games
against greece shocked and against Giri
very mysterious game where he had almost
winning position and managed to lose it
with some strange move moves ma'am
aronian probably also not very satisfied
wasn't fifty percent when he played
cards and had this great position but
lost it at the end and okay it seems
that he wasn't 100% in and in good
physical shape yes Villa the only player
without a win I think I okay besides a
Christine will have led eight drawers
and lost one game against Cara wanna
yeah he is probably not very satisfied
you never are if you don't win a game
but in this tournament though I mean if
you look at this he lost to elope points
it's he basically performed up to his
rating it's just always a bit yeah it
feels a bit emptier if you don't win a
game yeah Giri could have easily gotten
in on the higher in the sense and dis
tournament if he had won this [ __ ]
mentioned a couple of times game against
Aoki in this 130 bundles game very
up-and-down tournament with chances and
spoiled chances yeah and chrome dick
Motta tournament yeah after five rounds
he was leading the thing was plus two we
see here plus the two wins and then he
had this three losses yeah the disaster
loss against the two part of which
certainty was terrible for him and then
the the two games way he had at least
equal positions chances even today and
both he lost so I really I don't really
think that you will find many cases in
chronic scurry away he scored half point
out of four games I mean they have been
years probably only lost three games in
a whole year yeah and last play some is
some for the Norwegian number two seamen
Augustine who had a fantastic start
seven drawers and then lost two games
shaky game against Apollo and today
against Magnus yeah but minus two is is
a great result really he has not won a
game and he could have won games he had
two fantastic positions early on but at
the end this still means the rating gain
of 10 points yes performed far above his
rating expectancy yeah I hope you
enjoyed the coverage of this tournament
it it was interesting very very close
field you didn't have much you know you
don't have there wasn't one player
running away with it and and keeping a
lead or anything it was very very tough
competition um yeah I think the next
thing I'm going to at least briefly
cover um is the the rapid and blitz
championships maybe I'll do some some of
those rapid games if there is something
interesting to show I'm not doing any
daily something stuff but if there is
something interesting I might I might
show it and I'm not quite sure there
must be something until they loop yet
but I don't have it right now um yeah
I'm not quite quite sure right now what
happens until the limp yet which starts
a beginning of august there certainly is
some tournament in june and july but i'm
not i'm not aware of it at the mood okay
i hope you enjoyed this coverage and
i'll be back soon thanks